I have always loved playing golf the
problem is that for every good shot I
have far too many bad ones of course
anyone out here on the golf course would
tell you the way to improve that is with
practice and time time I don't have but
what I do have is a golf cart full of
golf gadgets I've been testing various
gizmos that work with your smartphone
and aim to make you a better golfer now
none have turned me into a PGA pro but
some are certainly worth checking out
the first one I tried the Zep Golf aims
to improve your swing you just clip it
right onto your glove and then it pairs
with your phone using sensors it
measures and records all sorts of things
about your swings including Club speed
tempo and backswing angle when I hit a
shot that felt good I tap this button to
favorite it and the app I would be able
to watch the swing to see what worked
set goals based off of it and watch
these instructional videos it was
helpful but not as helpful as when a
real pro watched me okay Joanna that was
a really good swing but I think if we
made an adjustment to your grip the ball
would stop going to the left and start
going straighter the next one's track
your game game golf and Arcos attached
little doodads to the top of your clubs
and then use GPS to track your round
except with game golf you have to wait
to see the information about your round
before every shot you have to awkwardly
tap your club to this be per size device
so you know where you've hit from and
then you have to plug it into your
computer what doesn't bring a computer
to a golf course our coasts worked much
better each tracker has bluetooth and
works in real time with my iPhone the
app showed me how far I was from the
next hole and because it collects
information on each club I hit I can
look up which one is best to hit with
the downside is that it only works if
you have your phone in your pocket since
it uses your phone's GPS the other
downside it registers every putt and I'm
a very bad putter
the last gadget to suffer through
playing a round of golf with me was the
Garmin approach s6 watch which really
does a combination of all the other
gadgets because the watch has GPS and
all the maps of the US course is built
right in it located what whole I was at
and how far I was from it more useful
where the arrows here that tell me what
direction I should hit my ball
there are also swing speed tools in here
but the interface is clumsy and the
touchscreen really doesn't work well you
know if you spent as much time
practicing as you did playing with that
watch and that's what I discovered I
liked the Archos and the Zep the best
because they quietly collected
information and didn't require me to
futz with them it was all about
concentrating on the game I love to play
now can someone just create a track of a
ball maybe something with Bluetooth so
we can find the darn thing